[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
cuba se levanta contra el régimen por
primera vez en casi 60 años los
ciudadanos salieron masivamente a las
calles para reclamar el fin de la
dictadura el presidente miguel díaz
canel culpó a eeuu de la miseria que se
vive en la isla mientras que yo va a ir
en aseguró que el comunismo es un
sistema fallido y siguen las
investigaciones del asesinato del
presidente de haití en el mois
washington y bogotá apoyan las pesquisas
para dar con el cerebro del magnicidio
que supuestamente sería un médico
haitiano que aspiraba a gobernar el país
caribeño más de 70 incendios forestales
consumen el oeste de eeuu las gamas
están ligadas al calentamiento global
que ya tiene efectos en la flora icónica
de los desiertos de norteamérica les
contamos desde arizona
y vamos de inmediato a cuba para nuestra
historia principal por primera vez en
más de seis décadas los cubanos salieron
masivamente a las calles en rechazo al
gobierno cansados de la escasez de
medicinas y alimentos los ciudadanos
lanzaron un grito para pedir un cambio
de mando en la isla que es gobernada por
miguel díaz canel quien heredó el poder
de raúl castro- en 2019 quien a su vez
lo heredó de su hermano fidel en 2008
en respuesta a las protestas el
presidente desplegó a las fuerzas
armadas y se vieron crudas imágenes de
la represión pero las manifestaciones
continuaron en todo el mundo de la mano
de los cubanos en el exilio para calmar
el descontento díaz canel eliminó
temporalmente las restricciones
aduaneras a los productos básicos
mientras culpaba a washington por la
situación económica del país
específicamente al embargo comercial que
restringe las actividades con la isla
pero realmente son las sanciones
estadounidenses la raíz del problema les
explicamos en el siguiente informe
en 1960 el presidente estadounidense
dwight eisenhower impuso las primeras
sanciones económicas en contra de cuba
tras la decisión de fidel castro- de
expropiar bienes y terrenos de empresas
de la unión americana en la isla era la
victoria a muerte los castigos incluían
la prohibición de importaciones de
productos cubanos lo que impactó
especialmente a la industria del azúcar
y llevaron al rompimiento de las
relaciones diplomáticas entre los dos
países mientras cuba establecía las
propias con la unión soviética
pero no fue hasta 1961 cuando john
f.kennedy estableció la prohibición
total sobre el comercio afectando
también las exportaciones a la isla
ese es el embargo actual que ha sido
aliviado y endurecido con los años
en 1994 durante el gobierno de bill
clinton se esforzó con la que se conoce
como la ley james bolton que buscaba
limitar también el comercio de otros
países con cuba'
pero en 2015 durante el mandato de
barack obama se alivió con el retiro de
las restricciones de viaje y la
reanudación de las relaciones
diplomáticas y la histórica visita de
obama a la habana
en 2017 con donald trump se dio marcha
atrás a estos alivios pero si bien es
cierto que debido a las leyes
estadounidenses para otras naciones
mantener relaciones comerciales con cuba
es más costoso la economía de la isla
empezó a verse perjudicada por la caída
de la unión soviética no por las
sanciones estadounidenses como lo ha
asegurado durante años el régimen cubano
todos estos procesos que hemos tratado
de enfrentar y de vencer ante una
política de asfixia económica para
provocar estallidos sociales en el play
guión efe
efectos acumulativos y precisamente yo
creo que hoy los problemas que tenemos
tienen que ver con esos efectos
acumulativos algo que el presidente joe
biden recordó esta semana al decir que
la situación de la isla es sólo
responsabilidad del que considera
fallido sistema del socialismo
el pueblo cubano está exigiendo su
liberación de un régimen autoritario no
creo que hayamos visto una protesta como
ésta en mucho mucho tiempo o francamente
nunca
eeuu apoya firmemente al pueblo de cuba
que está haciendo valer sus derechos
universales y hacemos un llamado al
gobierno al gobierno de cuba para que se
abstenga de la violencia oa los intentos
de silenciar la voz de los cubanos
un hecho que al parecer los cubanos han
empezado a entender
gracias paradójicamente a la apertura de
las comunicaciones y el internet hecha
por raúl castro- en 2015
vamos a ir para conocer los avances de
la investigación del magnicidio la
misión de los militares retirados
colombianos era proteger a emanuel
shannon el presunto autor intelectual
del operativo contra yo en el mois que
buscaba supuestamente que éste firmara
una carta de renuncia para lo cual fue
torturado como les explicamos en la
emisión anterior de aquí américa que
pueden volver a ver en nuestra página
web en el país caribeño había atenciones
por la fecha en la que el mandato de
moix debía terminar y shannon quería
hacer al parecer el siguiente presidente
yo en el moisés tenía muchos enemigos
por lo que aún no se sabe quién está
detrás de su asesinato pero las
autoridades haitianas negaron
contundentemente estar implicadas
después de que el noticiero colombiano
caracol citando fuentes de la
investigación
asegurara que el primer ministro club
josep estaba involucrado en el
magnicidio y hotmail la policía nacional
de haití niega formalmente las
acusaciones que señalan que las
autoridades haitianas y extranjeras
gabai una bola de la que están
trabajando en el asesinato del
presidente de la república jouvenel moix
formas yo siempre tienen pistas que
vinculan al primer ministro claudio set
12 a 18 ex militares colombianos de los
26 que habrían participado en el
magnicidio han sido arrestados según el
presidente del país cafetero
iván duque aunque todos participaron
pocos sabían lo que hacían dentro del
grupo de colombianos que han sido
capturados y algunos que que fueron
en tiroteos con las autoridades de haití
existen personas que por todo lo que se
ha ido conociendo tenían conocimiento de
ese magnicidio que se iba a perpetrar
por otro lado parece que dentro del
grupo había personas que habían recibido
instrucciones distintas pero seamos
también absolutamente francos
independientemente del nivel de
conocimiento que se tuviera lo que queda
en evidencia es que hay una
participación de todo ese grupo en ese
magnicidio como dice de origen humilde
quería cambios en haití que planteaban
serios problemas a algunos poderosos
según la investigación haitiana el autor
intelectual del magnicidio sería el
doctor christian emmanuel shannon un
médico residente en eeuu quería que moix
renunciará para reemplazarlo en el cargo
visitamos colombia para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana
el gobierno de iván duque presentó la
nueva reforma tributaria después de
verse obligado a derogar el anterior
proyecto debido al rechazo que despertó
y que hizo estallar en protestas a los
colombianos la iniciativa busca recaudar
fondos para hacer frente a los estragos
de la pandemia pero esta vez no impacta
a la clase media sino que se dirige
principalmente a las empresas también
busca recaudar dinero para cumplir con
los compromisos adquiridos con la
ciudadanía en el marco de las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales
el presidente de brasilia y
revolucionario fue diagnosticado con una
obstrucción intestinal tras haber sido
hospitalizado por un hipo crónico según
su equipo de prensa es una consecuencia
del ataque que sufrió en 2018 cuando
hacía campaña por la presidencia
el hecho se produce cuando bolsonaro se
encuentra en medio de una creciente
presión los ciudadanos se han
manifestado masivamente en varias
ciudades para criticar su gestión de la
pandemia del cob y 19 y un grupo de
legisladores estudia iniciar un juicio
político en su contra por un presunto
escándalo de desvío de dineros cuando
era congresista
y el líder opositor venezolano
reconocido como el presidente legítimo
por más de 60 países juan guaidó
denunció que el comando de operaciones
especiales de la policía venezolana que
es leal al gobierno de nicolás maduro
intentó detenerlo esta semana y que sólo
el operativo fue frustrado por la acción
de los vecinos que lo divulgaron en
redes sociales sin embargo si fue
detenido el diputado opositor freddy
guevara
y vamos a revisar la imagen de la semana
más de 70 focos de incendios forestales
arrasan con la costa oeste de eeuu el
más grande de ellos está en oregón miles
de personas se han visto obligadas a
evacuar sus hogares y miles de hectáreas
de bosque han sido consumidas por las
llamas una temporada de incendios
recrudecida por una histórica ola de
calor que también ha afectado a canadá y
que según expertos es indudablemente
consecuencia del cambio climático y los
científicos están preocupados
precisamente por el impacto que tiene el
calentamiento global sobre las
suculentas es decir las plantas que
acumulan agua en su interior el clima
extremo ya está teniendo efectos
visibles en el desierto de arizona hasta
donde viajamos en esta emisión
el desierto de arizona se transforma en
un mar de flores cada año al inicio del
verano pero este año algo extraño está
pasando en vez de crecer en la parte
superior de la planta los cactus también
han empezado a florecer en sus costados
las flores en este lugar son exactamente
un síntoma del cambio climático
a los investigadores les preocupa que
los recursos extra que se necesitan para
mantener las flores debiliten a los
cactus al punto de llevarlos a la muerte
las plantas se enfrentan cada vez más
duras condiciones debido al
calentamiento global
aquí no llovió una sola vez en un año
las cactáceas no sólo son el pilar del
paisaje sino del ecosistema necesarias
tanto para los pequeños mamíferos e
insectos que comen sus frutos como para
los depredadores que luego se alimentan
de esos herbívoros los voluntarios van a
trabajar al amanecer para huir de las
temperaturas de hasta 48 grados
centígrados que llegan a registrarse más
tarde están arrancando de esta hierba
que no sólo sólida que será aquí pero ha
empezado a ganar terreno a medida que
las temperaturas aumentan
le quita toda la nutrición y toma todo
el agua que hay aquí
las plantas nativas no pueden sobrevivir
y si no hacemos esto aquí ahora esto
lucirá en 100 años como el desierto del
sahara
además las especies invasivas se queman
rápidamente lo que alimenta los
incendios forestales hay que introduce
my park puedo hacer mi parte para ayudar
al planeta veo los efectos del cambio
climático cambiando el desierto
el cactus sahuaro sólo crece en arizona
y en el estado mexicano de sonora lo que
lo convierte en una planta icónica
fuente de orgullo local y nacional que
si se pierde sería muy difícil de
reemplazar pues cada planta tarda 50
años en alcanzar la madurez
[Música]
y me despido desde ciudad de mexico
donde se inauguró el cable bus el primer
teleférico para conectar las zonas
humildes de el norte de la capital
mexicana se estima que casi 150 mil
personas lo usarán cada día los usuarios
aseguraron que es una gran medida ya que
reduce el tiempo de traslado de una de
las zonas más desfavorecidas de una hora
y media a sólo media hora
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa soy natalia cabrera
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas en la producción estuvo luis
fernando montes recuerden que pueden ver
este y otros programas en france24 punto
com
[Música]